didn't hunter biden say he smoked
parmesan cheese or something like that
on the brink you know one thing about
meth mdma
methyl and dioxymethamphetamine which is
a type of meth
is used in like couples therapy because
if used right
certain types of meth are incredibly
good for you but
so meth the word meth gets a bad
reputation yeah amphetamine
and yeah certain types of amphetamines
if used in the right
environment can be beneficial crystal
meth though
i've never heard any any lab uses of
that yeah because i think it's
it takes a different form yeah you have
to chemically put this together in it i
think i think
adderall is for different amphetamine
salts or something like that
yeah so but you get into these weird
things man you say okay what if all
drugs were legalized and
and everybody can use any drug they want
so you just say you started using heroin
and you're a father of three children
you know you you can't be a dad smoking
heroin
all day or whatever how whichever way
you're doing it um you can't be a
productive dad doing these things and
and my thing is that you're not going to
grow it in your backyard you're going to
get it from somebody so if you can stop
the
person from delivering it then you're
going to save a lot more people than
just letting it flow through
good luck because they're getting it out
of afghanistan this is interesting
because uh
i'm i'm pretty libertarian when it comes
to drugs i'm fairly in favor of some
form of like mass legalization
but with some kind of regulation so the
idea would be you'd have to go to a
specialty clinic to buy it it's legal
and that way they can make sure you
don't overdose it's in a controlled
situation and they can get you off it
they can
slowly lower your dosage and help you
you know get away from withdrawal
symptoms and things like that
i i've often been a proponent of that
with there's one big caveat
that has no answer opiates already are
illegal
they are the doctors prescribe them left
and like like like sugar like like you
know sugar candies
and then people get addicted and then
they die from it yeah what
that's actually george floyd his
girlfriend testified
that they were both had some some
injuries in chronic pain and were
were prescribed opiates and then they
got addicted to it
that's a physiological dependence so
then they were like when the doctor
wouldn't give him any more they freaked
out and just started becoming
habitual drug users yeah i see that
happening but i think
i think you know you got the people that
become habitual people and you got
people that's just making excuses
you know when i go to the doctor and i
have any kind of thing i i i
like not to take drugs i just don't want
to take the drugs now if it's something
that you know
your leg is broken half and they got to
give you something antibiotics yeah and
then
yeah yeah ain't about they give you
something that's going to stop the pain
that could be a
you know a pretty harsh drug then you'll
take it you know my wife you know when
when she
after her pregnancy she had a c-section
and it gave her pain
pills but of course we're monitoring it
we're like
okay we're not gonna take that after you
need it
we're not gonna overdo it right we're
gonna balance
enduring the pain and not taking too
much but some people are you know they
people make excuses man and they they go
well i was addicted nobody told you to
take percocet
after you were after your illnesses were
over just because you had a big bottle
of the percocet
you need you need to some people sell it
we
the doctor prescribes crazy amounts of
drugs which i think that needs to be
regulated yeah
i think i think of my wife they gave her
a big old thing of pills i like she's
not going to need that many pills that
long
you know how much money she can get if
she sold him on the street
you know he talked about 25 50 appeal i
don't know how strong the appeal was but
you you're talking 20 some dollars a
pill and you got 200 pills in this thing
you can make money and people fake
injuries and they get injured and they
get in the dope game this way so
i think that we should regulate the
legalized drugs that we're already
administering to people
we should regulate those things and make
sure they're not abusing those things
and we should enforce these produced
unmanaged like you said you know these
drugs are not being
we don't know how they're making these
drugs yeah you know like i said sherm
you know you
smoking sherm is what i was referring to
smoking sherm
oh yeah with the formaldehyde with the
formaldehyde and marijuana and then
primos when i was
growing up that it's called primo where
you have weed but you put a little crack
somebody put crack in it
that's why when you you get your wheat
you gotta open it up and
go through it and make sure people
aren't putting pieces of crack or other
drugs in your marijuana
and so some people smoking primo and
they don't know it then they get a tick
addicted to crack crack or whatever
drugs that they end up lacing
these their marijuana with so i got to
pull this story up man because i i i'm
sorry
i think most of you may have seen the
story but i pulled up snopes
does everybody love snow they're so
accurate it's so accurate
did hunter biden say he smoked parmesan
cheese yes tell us
addicted to crack cocaine cravings often
drive decision making
true okay
that's it snopes confirmed that's the
case scene and the cheese i hear that
in an interview broadcast on april 4th
hunter biden the son of the president
said he mistook parmesan cheese for
crack in the past and accidentally
smoked the dairy product
they say while it was true hunter biden
said i probably smoked more parmesan
cheese than anyone
his statements implied that he mistook
other granular items for the drug during
the depths of his crack addiction
additionally it was false to frame that
quote as a confession
that he sought out and smoked parmesan
cheese specifically to try to get high
i still it's worse it's confirmed it's
worse dude
listen if somebody was like you ever
tried smoking parmesan i don't know
let's see what happens
that's that's not as bad as someone
being like i'm so addicted to crack
i'm going to smoke white powder i don't
know what it is you don't know what it
is
you know bread crumbs on the ground i'm
just going to start smoking everything i
see on the ground i'm just
on the ground just picking up stuff to
put in the pipe to smoke white powder
whatever it is i don't know what it is
dude
whatever smoked sage one time you guys
ever sprinkle i was like what
sage right here hold on hold on one
second
psychoactive or anything you can sniff
parmesan cheese like you can you can
take it
that's cheese yeah you can taste it it
smells smells like butt it smells like
butter yeah
maybe maybe maybe crack i don't know
somebody was hiding in there but it
smelled like that
yeah was it yeah that's what it was
somebody was traveling
somebody was hooping interiors that grow
on animal products i wonder why
i wonder why the prosecution i mean the
defense brought up um
like almost it feel as if floyd ingested
or
put something in his you know what they
did they did he they brought it
that was weird but nobody's that fact
haven't come out yet
but i'm wondering did they find rectal
i don't know but the defense asked the
question in the george floyd case he was
like
he said are you familiar with people
smuggling drugs in their rectum and
the defense was like no and then just
moved on right away because i feel like
they were setting up they were setting
some up later
they're going to have an expert come and
talk about something that pooping nobody
knows
i think they're going to go for hooping
because it's hooping when they
they're swallowing or it could be
anything it's storing
smuggling drugs in your body so when you
go to urban dictionary and you look up
pooping it says
shoving stuff up your butt you know what
i mean yeah people do it all the time i
mean i don't know why this is this would
be strange people do that all the time
when you're running around with dope you
hide it on your person of course but you
don't keep any
you don't walk around with a crack in
your hand and hey hey going to the store
rubber stuff hold on the rubber glove
you could put it you could put it in in
a craft parmesan cheese box
so in the context i don't think he was
talking about smuggling drugs because
he said i didn't do no drugs and then
when the cops like but you got foam on
your mouth as a yeah man i was hooping
i think he's basically trying to stay
he's saying playing basketball he's
playing basketball i mean that's not
obviously
i don't i think he was being like oh
yeah i shove drugs in my mouth i'm out
of my mind i'm losing it
so but he said i didn't take any drugs
right so is he saying he's lying all
over the place i didn't take any drugs i
just shoved him up my butt
nah he was saying i didn't take any
drugs i was hooping that's why i'm tired
that's why i got cotton
exactly he looked like a athletic guy
you know he had a luck tank top on he
probably was he'd probably still hoop
he'd probably still shoot my theory is
he was just
lying all over the place he tried to
sell a fake twenty dollar bill he
lied to the cops no told him he was yeah
we know he wasn't hooping
so i know he was like i wanna get to the
point of like why i bring up the store
with hundred buying smoking parmesan
cheese
this guy hunter biden can go on tv and
admit to the world the son of the
president is a crack addict
that smoked whatever white powder he
found on the underside of his table
the story about george floyd look it's a
big club
we know we're not in it barack obama
talks about he's like oh yeah i smoked
didn't did obama do coke i don't know if
that's sure he did
he said he did something in college
didn't he yeah i thought that's i i
don't know for sure
ta total absorption where they take a
hit of weed and you hold it in
until it completely absorbs in and when
you breathe out there's no that's that's
not what i mean i mean like
it's hardcore i never heard that's why i
just smoked when i was like i'm just
saying
if if you get caught and get arrested
for smoking pot
not so much now because it's
recreational it's legal now you're not
gonna be president
but obama can get elected and then come
out because he never got arrested look
when the story comes out about joe
hunter biden and the crack pipe and all
the stuff the media buries
it they don't want anyone to know so
it's you've got
you've absolutely got an elite class of
ultra privileged
drug addicts they just get away with it
they can do whatever they want
yeah because i think some of it they're
smarter you know where was he smoking
parmesan cheese probably in his house he
probably wasn't smoking parmesan cheese
on
on a corner of sixth in may or whatever
so the problem
is is that you know these crackheads are
so cracked out of their mind man they're
oh and they're
they're out and open doing cracks oh
yeah obama admitted to doing cocaine
yeah so but think about it how many
people done cocaine and never got caught
because they were doing it in the
in the prophecy at home they may have
escaped getting caught buying it from
the dealer
but i mean i think that there's a level
of stupidity that comes along with
people who get caught
when as a former police officer we
didn't get we used to have the saying
and it goes
every police department probably says
this you don't catch the smart ones yeah
you don't catch people that's smart yep
you catch the dummies
that are smoking weed driving down the
street banging music with the windows
down
smoking weed to the weed just flying out
of the car and
they drive by you and you're like okay
now everybody at the stop light is
looking at me like are you going to do
something about this
and i would have i would have never done
anything about it i could care less who
cares it's a little ticket that you're
going to get they're going to throw it
out in the court of law you're going to
waste my time
but you're doing you're just running
down the street banging music causing
attention to yourself and we
smoke is billowing out of that and in a
way you got to because if you don't
other people are going to emulate the
behavior and then everyone on the street
is going gonna be high driving
or not everybody knows but now you heard
like in a bunch of these states cops
can't pull people over for smoking weed
yeah i mean even even when you know for
smelling for smelling the weight
for smelling weed not smoking it right
because it's still impairment of dr
driving impaired but smelling marijuana
is not justification for us yeah it's
been
that's been gone for our department
that's been gone
probably since 2012 or earlier
it's when they started it was it was a
case that happened i can't remember the
name of the case but
um once they start legalizing
medical marijuana and stuff the smell of
marijuana is not a justification for you
going to somebody's house because they
could have a medical marijuana card
it's not justification however when you
put somebody on a traffic stop there's a
difference
between burning marijuana and fresh
marijuana so
burning marijuana in a car means nothing
you already smoked it i don't have
anything i smoked it
fresh marijuana is a different smell and
that can give you justification to stop
somebody and get a dog or maybe even go
into somebody's is that partly because
of intent to sell
because i think what i learned is is
that you have nothing left if you smoked
it
oh so you're just looking for the piece
i guess i fed cops pull me over
and then lie claiming they smelled pot i
don't smoke pot i've never
i've one time when i was a teenager with
some friends and i was like this is dumb
i don't care
what was the next step they said they
smell pot and then what did they say
then they
he he walked up to my car and i rolled
out so i got my
my wall of my keys on the dashboard i
got my hands on the steering wheel
windows roll down
cop walks right up and goes hey how's it
whoa what's that whoa
sir i smell marijuana and i went excuse
me and he's like
i'm gonna have to ask you guys the
vehicle and i was like okay and i get
out i'm in my work uniform so i have
these jumpsuits for for uh
the airline at o'hare and then he
immediately walks me to his car puts me
in cuffs calls for backup backup shows
up
secondary officer comes and holds the
cuffs you know in the middle and then
the cop goes and starts searching my car
without my permission
the other cop starts talking to me and
just small talk nonsense
the cop walks up and he's got what looks
like
some bit of plant and he goes what is
this
and i was like i don't know and he's
like it's marijuana and i was like
is it yours and he was like no i got it
from your car and i was like no you
didn't because i don't smoke
and he was like it was in your car and
i'm like i work at o'hare they do random
drug tests i work with plans i don't
smoke
and then he was like just confess and
this will be a lot easier
and i was like confess to what it's not
mine just confess
and it'll be a lot easier at this point
i'm talking to the other cop
and i guess i guess the one cop goes
back to my car and he's telling me that
it's going to be really hard for me it's
going to get a whole lot worse
unless i just admit right now that i was
driving under the influence that i've
been smoking
and i'm just like dude i don't smoke we
do random drug tests
at this point the cop who pulled me over
walks back over
and goes who's the firefighter and i
went my dad then the other then the
other cop uncuffs me and they go go home
kid
and they got in their cars and they left
i had uh a firefighter's emblem in the
glove box
yeah that my dad gave me and once they
saw that they backed up they backed off
but they legit i my car was full of taco
bell garbage wrappers
i don't smoke the drug like you work for
the airlines you get random drug tests
you're done you lose your job nobody's
nobody's smoking there yeah and so
that was it the dude pulled me over and
used the smell of marijuana
justification
to get me out of the car and search
everything and like legit i was
i was leaving work i'd work 16 hours i
don't smoke yeah i can see that
happening
you know some some cops they get they
get power hungry man and then
they don't want to do the real work they
want to do the easy route and so
if they can get you to admit to some
stuff that gets a rest or whatever
it's rare i mean because there's so many
people out here committing crimes
maybe if you're in a i don't know if
you're in a rural area or whatever but
see rural is probably they're probably a
lot more dicey because they don't have
to work
you their work in the city you can't
like
so it's too much work so it's like like
please stop
selling drugs like i'm just not gonna
arrest anybody anymore it's too much
it's like if you ever like tried to go
after people you'll be arrested people
all day long i mean all day long people
are doing crime so
but that doesn't excuse what happened to
you you know it's funny because when i
was a kid
i don't blame every cop friend yeah
because you because you know that but
see this is what i want to happen in our
societies that
empower people to be able to do what's
right in that situation when you get
hemmed up by cops that shouldn't be
doing what they're doing
not to defund the police department
right but let's let's let's spin
resources to empower people and let's
get those people turned in because
if you what could you have done in that
situation if i was a cop and i was
telling you like look
get their badge number you know and and
you your dad is a firefighter he was a
firefighter
and then report them and your dad will
have a lot more weight on the command
staff because this is what people don't
understand
command staff don't give a f about these
patrol officers
they care about publicity they care
about and not all
you get a little rural area in the
county somewhere they all buddy buddy
but in many police departments the
command staff
will review it and say you know what
screw that guy we'll run him over
this will make our department look good
and we'll do it to him let me tell you
my story from when i was like 15 in
south side of chicago
so there's a carnival they come and they
occupy certain blocks because they need
a parking lot and they need space
so the the these moving carnivals do a
deal with the residents
you know we'll make sure nobody goes on
your property well i had a friend who
lived in one of those houses
we go to the carnival we play the
quarter game we play you know squirt gun
game you know knock over the clown win
some prizes
we go and we sit on his lawn and we're
chilling and a security guard walks over
to us and he goes hey you guys got to
leave
and my friend goes this is my house i
don't care you gotta leave you can't be
here
and then he's like this is my house
where am i supposed to go
and then we get up and then i start
saying the same thing like my friend
lives here
one of the security guards grabs the
skin of my chest like just like he
pinches into my chest
and starts prodding my head saying are
you stupid
it's time to go and like yelling at me
so i'm like dude just like
left a physical mark on my body and i'm
i'm a little arrogant you know prick so
i immediately call my dad and i'm like
dude
this guy just walked up one on my
friend's property was told it was his
property
and then he physically grabbed me left a
mark and poked my head that's assault
and battery in illinois
my dad goes you're right what do you
want to do and i was like i want to
press charges and he was like i'll be
right there because there's a few blocks
from my house
he shows up he says who's the guy i'm
like it's those two guys there's an
older guy probably in his late
50s so he's like all right call the
police i call the police and i say
i'm on my friend's property security
guard just assaulted me
the cops show up and they walk over to
us and say what's going on my dad's like
this is my son
like you know pull up your shirt show
him your chest and i had like a mark on
my chest because he like you know
grabbed pinched into my chest and then
he's like and he's probably and all the
other kids who are with me are like yeah
he started
poking him on the head with his hand
like mocking and calling him dumb
and the cops like all right all right
we're going to the bottom of this we see
the cops walk over to the
security guards start talking shake the
hands of the guys
start laughing and then the guy walks
over and says listen
you know we're just gonna say you know
we're done it's no big deal
how about everybody goes home and i'm
like no no that's not how it works
i want this guy you know i want this guy
uh charged and they're like well we're
not gonna do that so my dad goes i want
a supervisor on scene now
white shirt shows up the white shirt
walks over to the
immediately to the guy who was was
screwing with me pats him on the
on the shoulder shakes his hand starts
laughing and smiling walks over to us
and says
here's what's going to happen your son's
going to be arrested for trespassing
or you can leave right now because it
turns out the guy who had
committed assault and battery i know it
wasn't the biggest thing in the world
but in illinois assault and battery is
when you you embarrass someone or touch
them
turns out he was a retired cop so there
was nothing that could be done so my dad
was a firefighter was like i'm gonna
file a complaint with internal affairs
and guess what happened
nothing it was just i could see that
happening yep
i mean i i could see it happening man i
mean it's to me
based on my experience is rare but if
you are
to think that cops aren't gonna
hold each other's back in some cases
they're not going to lie in some cases
then you must think that cops are gods
you know
there's some there's some fallible human
beings that make huge mistakes
and i want us to eradicate them
and you eradicate them professionally
professional eradicate the mistakes
yeah yeah eradicate their meaning
getting them out of the fine profession
um not killing them i like that word
eradicate
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you